vous connaissez bien l'histoire de
france et vous savez que notre pays est
un pays
génial absolument singulier avec un
génie particulier mais quand même
nous avons du mal à évoluer à nous
réformer dans la paix c'est souvent
brutale c'est souvent violents l'exemple
de samedi dernier est terrifiant quand
on voit ces scènes en plein paris une
rue dévastée par quelques centaine de
black blocks et nous sommes dans
l'incapacité de traiter ce sujet et ça
dure et ça dure depuis des mois comme ça
on peut pas se satisfaire de cette
situation il faut réagir il faut agir et
c'est pour ça que que j'ai écrit ce
livre plus vite que prévu très
franchement parce que je pense qu'on ne
peut pas rester inactifs après il est
clair qu'il ya des des sujets très
français un peu plus français que
d'autres
la difficulté finalement c'est qu'on
cumule les crises en simultané alors la
nouvelle la plus récente la crise
sanitaire qui est quand même très très
anxiogène en quelque sorte la crise
économique qui existait auparavant avec
les difficultés de la mondialisation le
chômage de masse qui va réapparaître la
crise sociale
on voit bien avec l'individualisme la
violence
la crise politique la crise d'autorité
le contexte géostratégique jeu je vous
en ai parlé
on pourrait continuer et c'est cette
simultanéité des crises qui qui crée ce
climat d'inquiétude
j'allais dire d'angoise parfois de
violence de peurs et tout ça est mélangé
et moi je suis un peu inquiet à court
terme à moyen terme je pense que la
france est un grand pays
quelle sera surmonté ses difficultés
avec une jeune génération des moins de
30 ans qui je l'espère sera faire face
aux défis en tout cas je sens quand même
dans dans les jeunes je vu dans l'armée
cette soif d'engagement de se dépasser
mais globalement à court terme
je suis inquiet parce que je vois cette
multiplicité de créer s'abattre sur un
pays qui est déjà en difficulté
oui
[Musique]